اجتاحت مشاهده مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
وخاصه في الايام الاخيره واصبحت ترند
مسلسل الهرش السبعه لامينه خليل ومحمد
شاهين واخراج كريم الشناوي استطاع ان ينقل
الحياه الزوجيه بما فيها من مشاعر
ومسؤوليات ومشاكل اسريه بواقعيه فوجد
المشاهد حياته اليوميه على الشاشه كما
جاءت معظم تعليقات رواد السوشيال ميديا في
حاجه في الحاجات الاجتماعيه في الحاجات
الدراما لايت بالذات بحس ده مع ان احنا مش
لايت قوي بس ابتدينا لايت بحس ده بيبقى
الناس
حباه في رمضان وحتى بره رمضان
بقيت حاسس ان في احساس عام ان احنا مش
قادرين على الثقل
ودي حاجه ابتدي اخد بالي منها من وقت خلي
بالك من زيزي مش معناه اي حاجه انا بحب
التقيل انا بحب الحاجات التقيل وبحب
الدراما الدراما بس الناس بقت عايزه اكتر
عن كبير في المسلسل الا ان العمل نقل
الحياه الزوجيه بتفاصيلها من خلال زوجين
ربطتهما قصه حب منذ الطفوله وكذلك خطوط
موازيه لازواج بظروف واعمار مختلفه ولعل
الحوار هنا الذي اعدته ورشه للكتابه
بقياده الكاتبه مريم نعوم كان البطل
الحقيقي معنا مخرج بيوضح لنا كل
الشخصيات هتبقى عامله ازاي بتفرح ازاي
بتزعل ازاي مشاكلها كانت ايه برضو مارينا
عمر كانوا موضحين كل المشاعر الحجم تكبر
كل الحاجات دي بتخليكي تبقي لمسه شخصيه في
حاجه وتعرفي ان انت تتفقي معاه في حاجه
فبالتالي تعرفي تقدميها
[موسيقى]
ربما لجماله الحواريه التي تفاعل معها
الجمهور ولكن يبدو ان المشاهد العربي
يفتقد هذا النوع من الدراما الاجتماعي
الهادئه التي تعرف بدراما الحياه اليوميه
سمر باشات العربيه القاهره لمتابعه المزيد
من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على يوتيوب الضغط على
زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات